un accueil en musique assurée
aujourd'hui par le groupe bois mappy des
rythmes traditionnels qui donne un air
de vacances et qui font le bonheur de
ces arrivants le vol a duré huit heures
comme d'habitude on était très satisfait
j'étais très agréablement surprise par
l'accueil fait en français et en créole
ça c'est bien mais à quoi pendant votre
séjour
une de mes cousines qui elle a déjà plus
depuis une semaine et puis on va visiter
l'île
[Musique]
c'est à la fois effectivement pour
souhaiter la bienvenue et permettre aux
passagers aux accompagnants aux
attendant de le faire dans les
meilleures conditions possibles c'est
vrai qu'un aéroport ça peut être un lieu
de stress donc avec ces pastilles
musical qui sont organisées çà permet de
détendre les passagers et puis pour ceux
qui arrivent c'est aussi leur premier
contact avec la culture martiniquaise
l'aéroport connaît depuis un mois et
demi une forte affluence entre quatre et
six gros-porteurs par jour avec des pics
de fréquentation pouvant atteindre
certains week-ends jusqu'à dix mille
passagers un dispositif grand départ en
partenariat avec les compagnies
aériennes été mis en place pour
permettre à chacun d'anticiper ces
formalités administratives et sur place
le faciliter les formalités
d'enregistrement
il a reconduit le dispositif d peste
verte où on a en fait des auxiliaires
qui sont pris pendant les vacances et
qui vont qui sont là pour accompagner
les passagers les guider
deux des banques d'enregistrement
jusqu'au poste pour les formalités de
police et donc voilà et qui vont
permettre en fait de fluidifier
notamment dans cette période de forte
affluence les allées et venues des
passagers et des accompagnants rien à
signaler à cette heure les gros porteurs
sont arrivés entre 12 et 19 heures avec
une heure d'intervalle en moyenne